was Trump who kind of woke Americans up
to the China threat but in Trump's mind
it was really just an economic threat he
wanted a trade War it morphed into a
cold war and that cold war has been
intensified by the Biden Administration
particularly the issue of Taiwan Biden's
talked about that far more than Trump
did Trump and John Bolton's Memoir
likened Taiwan to a Sharpie relative to
his desk China and I think it's obvious
from that particular exchange that Trump
does not think Taiwan is something worth
fighting for us part of what I think
Americans will remember that there were
no new Wars on Donald Trump's watch
I don't think enthusiasm for Ukraine
will be sustained it was the current
thing in 2022 it replaced black lives
matter in yards all over Northern
California but ultimately the big lesson
of of history is that American
commitment to foreign engagements even
if it's an indirect commitment in which
the Americans themselves aren't fighting
that that it fades